[Music]
how everybody got canceled even
inanimate objects got cancelled this
week
yeah mr potato head finally finally
yes this is one of those things where
i'm like are they doing this for the
publicity yes
yeah they have to be right like all you
this is literally the [ __ ] [ __ ] is a
button
if a company wants publicity for
something that is dying
right they literally have no nothing to
lose the product either dies
yeah or it bumps back into popularity
right so it either dies because nobody's
buying it anyway yeah it dies because
of the [ __ ] uh connection right and
people being really upset about it
or you make tons of money because all of
a sudden mr potato head gets cool i
think it's kind of like tv it's a last
ditch effort to guilt you into getting
it yeah
like tv's going trying to get whoa
because it's like nobody's watching tv
so they're going like
here's the thing we can do let's make
people feel like they
are morally obligated you know jana said
this to me back in the day i thought it
was so funny that like a
uh tv is acting like a nightclub that's
going out of business yeah
yeah like when nightclubs go out of
business they start going all right
here's latin night
here's gay night here's spanish night
they like tap into these really specific
niche groups and they're like we're just
gonna get all the money that we possibly
can
and then we're gonna close the [ __ ]
door yeah it's a final cash grab yeah
and you can see the numbers the numbers
are just like
but who's buying mr potato head for the
wokeness of it
so here's where i think they [ __ ] up
they should have gone conservative with
it
we're keeping mr mr mrs potato head
because we believe there's only two
genders
liberals would cancel it but they don't
buy anything anyway liberals aren't
buying their kids potato head dogs
conservative ceo these guys are sticking
to their guns saying [ __ ] you to pc
culture
i'll buy every [ __ ] mr potato head
proudly it's like the goya beans
yeah conservatives treat things that to
support their values like
indians treat indian comics they support
they come back
a country guy that said morgan whalen
yeah yeah just [ __ ] [ __ ]
through the roof of the roof number one
selling artists in the world apparently
to the moon bro
gamestop yo i mean look at jordan
peterson's book is like nine million or
something i mean he's selling millions
of copies
yeah you know in canada it's like number
one he sent me a copy yeah
i said uh you want to come on the pod to
talk about it and then the pr firm was
like oh ask him i never heard back
yeah not reading your book jordan
not until your balls drop and you sound
like a man
[Laughter]
well uh let's talk a bit you know
sounds like a [ __ ] eunuch 12 rules
for life
let me say here
it's about it's about cleaning your room
clean your room fluff your pillows
you'll feel better with fluffy pillows i
mean we live in an era where you can
sell [ __ ] tons of books all you gotta
tell people is like
there's two there's two sexes and people
go hi he's a genius yeah isn't that
crazy
the most famous philosopher on the
planet by going i think
guys are guts how many dudes on the
corner
have been saying the exact same thing no
12 rules for life nothing
yo if you got a [ __ ] yeah you're a girl
i think bro
hey two rules guys are guys girls or
girls
if you don't ignore that if you actually
don't ignore that one athlete that's
three feet tall than the other ones and
was born with a dick you're a genius
book like a master p album like he would
just put more songs on his [ __ ] than
everybody else because you would just
buy it if there's more songs
jordan peterson got two rules guys are
guys girls or girls but he's like we
need like 10 more
give it 12 so we can sell this book you
can't have a two rule book
yeah that's true two rules it's too
little that's not a book i'm not
investing in that 12 rules 12 steps
12 12 is the number 12 isn't up 12
months of the year
almost 13. how many 12 disciples
how many inches of dick is giannis
missing 12.
yo 12 bro yo how much
how many millions would have history
hyenas made if we stayed together 12.
how many is chrissy going to make on his
own 40.
a hundo
[Laughter]
but he's yeah
that is so true isn't that crazy like it
nowadays philosophers and thought
leaders are just people saying
common sense [ __ ] yeah what does that
say about society we've gone
so far left or so far right that all you
need to do
to be an intellectual is say what you
already
feel greatness is over in fact
the attack the the the attack for in the
name of morality
is a great sentence to start with
because what you're going to follow up
with it has nothing to do with it but
i'm going to listen
no it's going to be good okay god
tom brady win a [ __ ] super bowl at 43
years yeah it's over bro
yeah i'll throw something
okay go oh they attacked the attacker
starting every sentence with greatness
and they're just saying some completely
nonsense when they attack you for
something you did
to try to make you morally pure that in
itself is an attack on greatness
name me one personally impure you're
saying impure yeah
they want you to be pure yeah name you
one great person
who was pure michael jackson tom brady's
a great example he's michael
jackson r kelly michael jackson you're
absolutely pure
yeah nothing is more pure yes than the
loins of a little boy
yes hey the greek you would you [ __ ]
feed him like tokens and that's how he
achieved his greatness
[ __ ] boy tokens put it in the machine
and watch him dance that's
you're making my point
and watch him tom brady's a perfect
example he left
his pregnant girlfriend for giselle yeah
no
she tried to trap him so what you banged
her up
stay like but he thought he could trust
her so what you banged her up
he votes republican he's bad he's bad
right yeah so that's another one that
[ __ ] knows how to leave a
sinking ship don't you he does
he got out of what is it bridget
moynihan he got away from her right in
time
he went to tampa yep i mean this guy i
trust his decision-making yes and he was
ballsy enough to make it he's not loyal
how is he not loyal he's been loyal
giselle no he's well we don't know that
she wasn't loyal to him
he's well we got to check his [ __ ] she
lied to him she was like yeah i'm on the
pill this that the other and then she
got knocked up
who gizelle no oh the other [ __ ] yeah
but
yeah i mean she's just google maps face
nobody knows about her yeah she has it
tom brady's seed that kid could grow up
to be something yeah but he's new brady
not have anything to do with that kid
huh is brady not having anything that
kid is always with him i don't know i
assume that's one of his brady should
ignore him so he has a chance to be
great so he has something to conquer
now that he's coddling him the kid's not
gonna do anything he's gonna end up
being a dj on drugs
but if you ignore that kid that kid ends
up being great look at shaq
look at other kids phil is my father he
didn't have a real father so he became
an animal he became one of the best
players shaq shaq had a military step
dad yeah but
phil but his father figured but he
didn't have a real dad sean king
dad doesn't know mysterious
light-skinned black guy becomes a great
philosopher on the internet activist
because he overcame obstacles in order
to achieve greatness
you got to overcome obstacles yeah it is
tough because sure people don't overcome
you can't overcome options
jeff bezos got one eye the other eye is
evil no
yeah jeff bezos doesn't know his real
dad doesn't know his real dad
he didn't miss steve jobs dawg steve
jobs steve jobs
adopted yeah yeah andrew schultz mother
never hugged him mother never hugged me
there you go she will dance with you dog
she will
yeah she did she will replace hugs
mom it worked out
you see what i'm saying like greatness
and greatness
and morality are almost diametrically
opposed
where you go it seems like greatness and
a lack of love
are parallel you can't you have to do
some dirty [ __ ]
in order to achieve greatness i don't
know
i don't know dirty but i don't know if
that's dirty i don't know what tom brady
did is dirty
tom brady probably was mean to his
teammates probably
a bunch of teammates love him yeah
teammates absolutely love playing with
him
all right so this is going on people
love
yeah yeah minstrels michael jordan one
because he's a dick that that that's
greatest of all time
you're telling me tom brady's nice that
no tom buddy gets in your face and he
yells come on dude yeah
you